he went wild let's talk about Heaven's
Gate oh my god
I don't know about it no you don't know
what Heaven's Gate is we were listening
to sword in scale shout out to the
doctor sorta to share scarer scale not
the movie not the movie no the cult the
cult you know about them a little bit it
was they were in San Diego they were
found in a mansion 39 people people they
were all wearing purple robes they're
all wearing black Nike shoes that's
pretty cool and they all had a role of
course okay on them mm-hmm this is the
only way I think they can get onto the
comet it to pay in quarters an American
currency I think so yeah and they all
killed themselves why the Nike shoes
that's what went out no it's not because
of training they like the they like and
doing research they like the motto I'm
just doing right and they believed in
that they could spiritually if they
killed them so that you know that I was
a comment called it was called police
maybe Halley's Comet not Halley for what
the cop look it up yeah anyway today but
there was a comet coming and or you know
and they thought that they when they
kill themselves that they their souls
would enter a spaceship that was
following the comment and they'd be
extraterrestrial beings they could be
right it's a Haley Bob comment I'll be
Bob Collins yeah but yeah Heaven's Gate
was a big call and I I'm creating a cult
here a tiger belly how do we die writing
a book we're gonna write a book yeah
we're gonna really write a Bible or
releasing we're gonna release it and
we've got Commandments we've got ways to
live but definitely no mass suicide
that's associate hockey hockey at the
chest as if you died yeah like you're
not yeah
but there's all these little rules and
name some rules I want to hear him well
I am NOT I'm just a prophet okay just
the Prophet just a prophet I'm but I'm
evil to everyone I'm not the leader
okay okay I'm a symbol okay okay like
probably you still have to worship me oh
all right so we worship an equal we're
equal but you still have to worship me
and will we get our compound we will
have a compound and we will have things
that happen are do the men live
separately cuz you know in heaven scape
they weren't allowed to engage in sexual
activity there is no other men in there
oh it's all women well YouTube that's it
what the [ __ ] that's a sex dungeon for
you know maybe I'm maybe I'm monogamous
to you and you're my life
okay but you know in my vision it's not
me it's God no everyone I can't help it
I receive the information through God
and so it's still Oh God if we're going
to be a legitimate cult we have to allow
all men because they'll be involved
they'll be they're not in the compound
but they'll be involved out in the
fields in the field what are they doing
in the fields they're pickin things oh
not me
okay well my worst fear lint or
something out of bellybuttons no I'll
just throw things out there you have to
pick it I don't know I don't get it why
we just picking up his trash listen I
don't want to reveal my I don't want to
reveal my new religion Mike all right
now all right I'm in the process of
communicating with God okay and he'll
give me the inspiration and he'll write
it through my hands
can I just ask one thing yeah go ahead
interested yeah can you give a little
bit about the afterlife with your cult
oh yeah oh sure yeah oh yeah you'll be
reincarnated oh okay but in the past you
know how you get yeah you know how you
people at people believe in
reincarnation is like this oh my god I
and then in the food so I can be
accorded a dolphin in a 1950 I already
know I'm gonna tell you what you're
gonna be the leader tells you what
invision yeah you're gonna behave don't
tell me I don't want to know my my
destiny yet I'm not ready to hear it my
choices you're gonna be a whole excuse
me uh leader Corey hole or ground
well I'm all I'm gonna say this you're
gonna be a fantasy [ __ ] all okay Walt
that's and that's your name that's my
worst night what decade now you said in
the past or what oh I'm a [ __ ] hole in
what a thousand years you're a harlot
from like medieval days yeah Game of
Thrones Game of Thrones [ __ ] and the
Scottish are involved Scottish men are
involved and you're just gonna be you're
gonna be in a cage as a whole as a whole
yeah you're yeah well they're not gonna
see your face could we cook it oh I'm
still a person you're a human being
whole you know you're a human being okay
well we cover your human yeah you're
giving good so if don't die then god no
time but when you get reincarnated into
the past right you're just gonna wake up
and you're just gonna be in a cage
okay your face and your body is covered
except for your butthole and you're
constantly in a bent-over position oh
right and it's a cage with no bars
basically what it is it just has your
ass cheeks a box my butt is not that
wide yeah ridiculous what they're gonna
feed you a lot you're my butter my mouth
into your mouth thank you
no you're gonna be really fat you have
these gigantic butt cheeks right and
there's gonna be like fingernails
sticking out of them from other people
oh it's not gonna be good right and
they're just gonna just like grab it
with their fingernails and that's what
I'm gonna put out we have a sign okay
I'm gonna grab these chicks did you use
your nails okay that's not a god that's
using those so pretty so I got a vision
you're adding this sweet Erick soft
right like you the well it uh silence of
the lid okay
just know you know condom no sheepskin
nothing big raw doggin just gonna be
miles of people okay and that's you if
we have to kill this afterlife but the
whole community only has one fantasy
[ __ ] hole so they all have to [ __ ] him
the whole country Scotland Scottish all
Scotland and also some Irish and some
English but you're just gonna be this
[ __ ] fantasy football example so
that's one example of this new religion
that we're creating wow yeah it's a
great one
I'm not I'm not sure carnate in the past
I'm keen on this yeah I was really
excited before this no oh you he's kind
of the same thing but in the dinosaur
age in strange dinosaur claws it's his
blood shitty roxas and all kinds of [ __ ]
in your [ __ ] kid
[Music]